tonight saw right foot although if it
was a playoff game he would be in there
levert bumping body trying to hook a
pass inside it's a turnover
he can score especially as a plate
because his three-point shot has been so
effective
Olynyk the quick move underneath and
Wade finds him roaming basil no changes
so far way trying to get on the board
and does beautiful ball fake Twain way
here's Wade against Graham the back end
the extra move wait the connection game
of the g-league finest that was a loss
for the long island net so there will be
a decisive Game three at Stony Brook
[Applause]
high screen not a bio Wade shows the
ball bounces Olynyk great field
as olynyk rocks the rim subvert and ways
been playing lately and wait pass once
again Dwyane Wade in the middle of the
floor making things hence too strong
from ku roots grabbed by Jones Miami
trying to run Wade - special delivery
flows a great pass by Napier way drives
leaves it for Haslem give a strap strap
on the front tight meta is five of seven
from three-point territory way to the
rim to pain Wade
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
way the spin on a land hooks inside for
June
Dwyane Wade the edge of the floor here
at Barclays center
I didn't know that opening was big
enough Wade inside for two
8350 for Brooklyn
Robinson cuts and scores OOP on that
path from Dwyane Wade floor his feel for
the game reason why he's one of the best
Allen denied by Wade rebounds 7 assists
for Dwyane Wade Wade crosses over Allen
yes on the side I have never seen Erik
Spoelstra smile so much about the course
of coaching a game Robinson a 3 I did by
Wade that triple-double is going to
happen
that's 10 rebounds now for Wade Dwyane
Wade
I was in 42 made threes Robinson the
step back JD Kansas 50 seconds to go on
the third Wade gives it up
pass on the bucket yes in his final NBA
game
[Applause]
paid fakes coup routes gets a piece
weighed saves would tend to shoot out a
pie oh the screen
Wade's jumper he hats night in Texas for
the g-league Long Island Mets tonight
for the Brooklyn Nets Wade sticks it
from long range
[Applause]